they're pounding online gambling in
Nevada and Airbnb in California but this
month we zero in on well California but
also Maine because the bipartisan Senate
do of Dianne Feinstein and Susan Collins
is messing with small-time soap makers
and looking squeaky clean in the process
pay attention all you state Reps looking
to take the next step these senators
know how to play the game step one
scare voters think chemicals from
formaldehyde to dihydrogen monoxide
voters are scared of them so go regulate
some the press will help spread the fear
and don't worry reporters won't mention
that something that might be dangerous
and large concentrations can be
perfectly safe in small ones do you want
to put red dyes on them do you want the
carcinogens and parabens high dose step
to chrony up assemble a list of
well-known companies that support your
bill bill shield you from charges that
you're an anti-business nanny
they might even donate to your campaign
after all you're shielding them from
competition by dumping regulations on
their smaller competitors step 3
choose a great name voters figure your
bill will do what it says so call it
something like you know the personal
care product safety app voters love
personal care and they definitely love
safety plus if someone questions the
effectiveness of your bill just point to
the name don't worry about all those
self-employed women who own small
businesses and make soap and cosmetics
by hand if they're complaining about not
being able to afford your bills fees and
reporting requirements then they
definitely can't afford to contribute to
your campaign what happens now I mean
you've got all these products they're so
popular but where do you want this suit
to go from here well I'm just hoping
that like the whole world stops using um
don't look so follow nanny the month on
Twitter submit your nanny nominees and
check back next month for more examples
of busybodies minding other people's
business
you